I don't know about you but when I was
younger I used to have the worst anger
problem especially when it came to
playing video games and my brother
specifically playing video games with my
brother no you can't return this
cheating okay
I'll be protest no I'm from Tosh not
always Protoss ok I'll be sir
no this time mass-produce like way too
fast I don't know what you want from me
I was never a very gracious loser damn
it stop harassing my workers I'm not
proud of the way I used to act and the
bathroom is actually really really
embarrassing holy shit my room now we
actually used to do that like whenever
we would piss the other one off we would
lock their room and then proceeded to
destroy it
it was horrible I don't really know why
or when my anger problem went away
whatever the reason is I am so glad I am
not like that anymore
winning is just it's not important and
in the end all that matters is that you
tried your best ok
good game new holes a nice try what
don't pack tonight bad day awesome
Gotham do I get your face out of like
sands ok ok make it go all the tires now